these migrants are taking what's become
a well-traveled route the Coast Guard
has told the volunteers here on the
north coast of the Greek island of
lesbos to expect a boat in about 20
minutes and that's the fourth foot today
yes it into a eight boats and they
before they were like ten boats today
three more are expected NGOs say the
number of boats has fallen since the e
use agreement with Turkey now there are
more controls at the well-known starting
points on the Turkish Coast moas wanted
to get to lesbos a week ago we tried
twice and the Turkish police kept
catching us then on our third attempt it
worked thank God but now most migrants
have to try different routes which are
often longer and more dangerous than
those used before the agreement the
missing migrant project has already
registered more than 90 deaths in the
East Aegean this month double the number
for the whole of November but in this
case they are all good they are not
they're not sick people in boats so but
usually they are the most problems at
this moment of the years that they are
really cold and there could be a big
problem with your two or three hours in
the in the boat and you have wet clothes
on and dr. Siddiqui knows what he's
talking about when he was 12 he came to
the Netherlands as a refugee from
Afghanistan now he's taken extra holiday
to help out and here on lesbos he'll
have his work cut out for him